[Music]
hi
lucy good morning it's me henry
we are on i think about our 5
000 date together it's been great i want
to catch you up
[Music]
you have a thing called amnesia and i am
your husband
we have a daughter and she's about
40 now or something like that what i
know it's bananas
uh but i'm not done yet it's 2020
and we're also in the middle of a
pandemic
which is a terrible thing baseball games
are now being played in front of
cardboard people
sounds kind of like you're making this
up oh yes if the
room you're in right now smells uh a bit
like
farts uh that was that was you it does
kind of smell like farts in here are you
sure that wasn't you
oh it doesn't matter either way there is
good stuff going on in the world though
there's a company called
netflix that provides premium
entertainment to people right in the
comfort of their own home
uh they also pay me so that's why we can
have that house together
so to recap 2020 is it's not great
uh netflix is is good uh
and you fart uh a lot in your sleep
true in all seriousness though i want to
just tell you this i can honestly be
more excited for you
you have your own show now hi i'm tom
lucy's got her own show now tom
yes yes 10 second time that's right
that's great
who's lucy and why is everyone outside
wearing a mask
okay tom that's enough you gotta go now
okay
you're gonna make people so happy every
day every time they see you
you are magic the whole world feels it
and i'm lucky that i know you so well
i love you i can't think of any endeavor
i'd ever want to do without you
adam so thanks and i love you
hi i'm tom